[Applause]
[Music]
it's that time again another exciting
episode of Cairo West and a hum Lord
King David
um I'm happy to bring the statue to you
because a lot of controversy went down
with my last statues with main walk and
people were like oh but the real king of
the deep is Aquaman you know uh you know
I said well you know facts is facts and
I laid out the facts before you but for
you DC heads
I'm definitely toldja has something for
you and this is this bad boy right here
I love the polls I love everything so
let's give you a little bit of history
about author now author Samuel Eto'o
someone who shall not be named from
Marvel is a son of a fisherman who fell
in love with that lanten princess and
sired a child and you know he became the
the king of the deep got Neptune's
trident C DC characters are larger than
life DC characters mainly are
disconnected from the normal folk and
are like gods so to say you know Aquaman
he's on par with Superman you know um
strength-wise speed wise he's a
tactician highly combative
you know there's really not much that
Aquaman can do he can actually talk to
the anima next a molecular level the
parasites that are inside your body
that's swimming your bloodstream
that's how telepathic he is so Aquaman
is a very intriguing character when you
get to it you know get down to
everything so i'ma go to the DC Universe
right and they use Jason Momoa so I
thought they must cast him to be honest
with you I never thought that he fit the
role of Aquaman does it look like
Aquaman doesn't fit the mold of Aquaman
but after seeing the movie I notice who
did Patrick Wilson
I thought DC missed a huge opportunity
and casting Patrick Wilson as Aquaman
look at these pictures this is the head
of Aquaman of the Premium Format and
this is Patrick Wilson's face
you tell me doesn't he look like Aquaman
the fact that they casted him in the
role of ocean master Aquaman's brother
half-brother in the movie was kind of
disheartening I thought the movie was
miscast not saying that it was a bad
movie actually it's one of the better
DC Universe movies with Shazam probably
being the pinnacle of the DC Universe
movies and Aquaman coming in a whole
second um I just really thought they
missed cast and it would have been
better off had they left Jason Momoa to
something else and cast Patrick Wilson
would have been a better film to me
great actor well let's get into the
statute this is the e ex exclusive
Premium Format
statue from sideshow now what makes it
Premium Format you say king right well
it has to switch out heads and to switch
out arms as you can see right there this
comes out with a load of switch outs
which is really um different for
sideshow when it comes to premium
formats usually premium formats probably
have like one switch off these ball
portrait portrait being the head so
that's really what they do but this one
actually had four parts for the switch
out now I'm really pleased with it
you have him with the beard we have him
Aquaman without the beard on his what is
that his right hand nope that's his left
hand on his left hand he has a hand and
he has a spare as a switch out in the
books
Aquaman lost his arm and I got chopped
off in the midst of battle and he
fashioned the spare onto it was a gritty
time in Aquaman's life when it was going
on different directions with the
character so the statue has that aspect
of it so you can display the statue
pretty much how you want to display you
don't even have to have the spare in his
hand you can just have him up there with
his fist and on I mean to try it I'm
sorry
and it's hand i think this statue the
base is incredible if you look at the
base the base is insane the level of
detail on the base with the water
splashing up against the stone pillars i
I really honestly love this base I think
it's a highlight of the statue
this statue is of the top quality
highest quality
I can't um illustrate how the chainmail
on the suit shines with the gold the
green looks like a um a leafy coral
green very nice very well done very well
painted the head scopes are beautiful um
like I said I love the porches I love to
switch outs
this is a great statue now it's around
that time where I'm going to tell you to
like follow and subscribe and also go to
the Lords of gaming dotnet where you're
gonna get the dimensions of this
character alright so when you go to Lord
to game you got net you go up to the
iron Lords category and you click it and
the submenu is gonna pop down you get a
ckos
you're gonna see combat talk with the
King and you're gonna see the last word
a little kognito and advantage we can
get all that lose the shooter news right
now destiny is on a high they just
announced the new DLC coming for the
fall you have a whole bunch of
information coming also the website has
a ton of entertainment moves sports news
and video game news man you're not on
Lords of gaming net where are you at
baby so check it out
listen I want y'all to continue to watch
the video so you can see this statue in
all its glory and next week I got
something that makes the cap me yeah see
you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]